les soldats ukrainien dans les tranchées
de la première ligne face à dos nièce
occupée par l'armée russe nous l'avait
dit nous sommes prêts pour la contre
offensive dès que l'ordre sera donné
et ils sont passés à l'offensive près de
kharkiv assiégée par les russes et à 10
y sommes sur la ligne de front de 400
kilomètres du donbass
parce qu'alors qu'on s'attendait à un
assaut massif on se rend compte que la
poussée rue snowdon basse et qualifié d'
anémique sur les sept tentatives
d'assauts qu'on a réussi à documenter en
essayant de faire la remontée des médias
sociaux on a vu qu'un avait seulement 2
qui avait réussi avec des avancées pour
les russes qui sont minimes qui sont de
1 à 2 kilomètres par jour dont qui sont
vraiment très réduite et puis finalement
souvent ce n'arrive pas être consolidée
parce qu'à une contre-offensive
ukrainienne c'est ce qu'on a vu à lyon
où soixante quinzième jour de la guerre
les russes n'ont pas beaucoup de
réussite à afficher
alors que les ukrainiens se glorifie la
destruction récente de deux vedettes
rapides en mer noire
ainsi que du croiseur amiral moss femmes
avec aussi des frappes à l'intérieur de
la russie et la mort de douze généraux
russes sur le terrain oui bien
globalement un mort toutes les semaines
un général qui meurt toutes les semaines
mais simplement représentatif de ce qui
se passe tout en bas également on a
maintenant réussi à documenter la perte
d' à part de la russie de 3500 blindés
3500 blindés matériel des chars des
tanks des systèmes de défense des
systèmes d'artillerie c'est juste
colossal c'est plus qu'une armée comme
l'armée française qu'ils ont déjà perdu
aujourd'hui à côté ça on estime qu'il ya
environ quinze mille soldats russes qui
sont morts et environ 30 mille blessés
plus certainement des centaines de
prisonniers donc tout ça fait que soient
les 150 180 mille hommes qui avaient été
engagées par la russie il y en a
probablement un tiers qui sont
aujourd'hui totalement inapte au combat
et le problème c'est que la russie a
déjà engagé plus de la moitié de son
armée en ukraine la lourde défaite des
environs de kiev pourrait-elle se
reproduire dans l'est et le sud est on a
comme l'impression mois là le sentiment
que j'ai c'est comme quand on avait fait
cette vidéo deux semaines avant que la
russie renonce à prendre kiev moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on est dans la même
situation dans le bande basse et autour
de kharkiv les russes donnent
l'impression qu'ils sont dans
l'incapacité de continuer à avancer et
qui subissent des attaques de plus en
plus fréquentes et nommera un nouveau
lotissement cossu en attendant la vraie
contre offensive est annoncée par le
conseiller de la présidence olexi
arresto beach pour la mi juin
le temps de recevoir et de se
familiariser avec le matériel militaire
moderne envoyer massivement par les
alliés
alors que les sanctions contre la russie
ont mis un terme à la production
d'avions et de blindés les plus modernes
faute de pièces indispensables venus de
l'ouest le temps joue clairement en
faveur de l'ukraine
jean-michel passera du canada montréal